Jackie Burkhart was a career-defining role for
Mila Kunis, but there's something she
finds unnerving about "That '70s Show."
Regarded as one of the funniest sitcoms in TV
history, "That '70s Show" appeals to audiences
young and old with its nostalgic subject matter
and endearing portrayal of teenage life. As such,
it's no wonder that the show's immense
popularity helped launch the careers of
its young cast which included the likes
of Ashton Kutcher, Wilmer Valderrama,
Laura Prepon, Topher Grace,
and of course, Mila Kunis.
Kunis, in particular, has enjoyed an enormous
amount of success since her breakout role as
Jackie Burkhart in "That '70s Show," scoring a
recurring role on "Family Guy" as the voice of
Meg Griffin and starring in prolific films
such as "Forgetting Sarah Marshall," "Black
Swan," and "The Book of Eli." Considering the
many notable and successful projects she has
been involved in since the 2006 conclusion of
"That '70s Show," it might surprise some fans
to learn that she actually refuses to watch the
series for one admittedly understandable reason.
During an appearance on the "Happy
Sad Confused" podcast in October 2022,
Mila Kunis confessed that she has
never actually seen a full episode
of "That '70s Show." The actor went on
to explain that she finds it too odd
to see her most awkward teenage years
preserved on camera for all to watch.
Kunis' reluctance makes sense when considering
the fact that she infamously lied about her age
to join "That '70s Show," jumping onto the main
cast when she was just 14 years old. Where most
people might get away with simply avoiding
old yearbook photos or trying not to remember
their awkward phases from high school, Kunis has
several full seasons of television that document
her teenage years. Still, while she may prefer not
to spend a lot of time revisiting her adolescence,
the actor isn't completely opposed to giving
"That '70s Show" a shot. As she explained,
"If it ever goes back to broadcast, and if
it comes on, then I think I'd watch it."
While Mila Kunis hasn't watched "That '70s Show,"
it doesn't appear to have anything to do with her
experience working on the show itself. In
fact, the actor has spoken quite positively
about the filming environment for the series.
She shared in an interview with Vanity Fair,
"I had the greatest experience on
''70s.' 100 percent, I was embraced."
"I was never treated as lesser-than,
and if I did by one of the cast members,
another cast member would stand up for it."
Kunis has also talked about how difficult
it was to leave the show behind when it
came time for the finale in 2006.
Kunis said on "The Ellen Show,"
"On the day, I couldn't stop crying. I literally
reverted to being a little kid and
I just wanted someone to hold me."
But while the program may have ended,
the story of Jackie Burkhart didn't.
Though it took over a decade and a
half for the opportunity to arise,
Mila Kunis didn't turn down the chance
to play the iconic character once again.
She and her husband Ashton Kutcher, who
portrayed Michael Kelso in the original series,
returned to their classic roles for Netflix's
2023 spin-off "That '90s Show." Jackie and
Kelso pop up in the first episode of Season 1,
appropriately titled "That '90s Pilot," with
the latter giving Kurtwood Smith's Red
Forman a headache for old times' sake.
While Kunis admitted to Access Hollywood
that it was a strange experience to be
filming opposite her husband once again,
she lavished praise on the overall production.
Prior to the show's debut, the actress said,
"It's very sweet. It pays
homage to anyone who's ever
watched ''70s' or loved '70s Show,'
they will be really happy with it."
At the same time, considering that Jackie ends
up with Wilmer Valderrama's Fez in the "That '70s
Show" finale, Kunis does find it a bit odd that
Jackie and Kelso are an item in "That '90s Show."
At the end of the day, even though
she hasn't gone back to watch it,
"That '70s Show" will always remain a standout
part of Mila Kunis' career and pop culture legacy.